s'il est en effet de rester à lyon oui
je pense que ça être vieux petit
mûrement réfléchie c'est la période des
vacances avant qu'un jour c'est parce
que ça nous arrive de tourner les
vacances en même temps que moi en plein
on a décidé à l'unanimité on la touche
bien pensée on en a parlé comme obama de
ne pas les entendre dans ces conditions
on veut profiter de florac à beaugas et
peignoir mais bravo et tiens j'ai un
petit cadeau pour vous plus tôt non mais
c'est vrai j'avais le cadeau pour
raymond tenez ces polices et pour ses
sourcils
[Applaudissements]
attention cette attention blesser
personne aves important pour lui et
qu'ils n'abîment pas jean michel baylet